a while back we we booked this contest
musical group this kind of wacky musical
group called the slip nuts and we booked
them on the show we didn't know anything
about them and they came on the program
they're called the slip nuts and let's
just look at this this footage from a
couple years ago of these slip nuts in
action and slipped on some nuts that was
basically their entire act slipping on
nuts while singing about slipping on
nuts so if you can imagine we were more
than hesitant to book the slip nuts a
second time but the slip nuts kept
calling and they assured us they had
worked up a brand new routine that we
were going to love here's a clip of the
slip nuts second appearance on our show
[Applause]
I slipped on some nuts couldn't believe
it yeah they claimed that this act was
different because their sweaters were
polyester on the first appearance and a
cotton blend on the second appearance
well after that we refused to have the
slip nuts on ever again then earlier
this week the slip nuts
started calling begged us for just one
last chance they say they've had a
couple of years now and they promised me
they freshened up their act that's
different now I for one I'm just curious
to see their new direction once again
ladies and gentlemen here are this slip
nuts
[Applause]
[Laughter]
that's where the Slipknot's women are
nuts look evil bad I slipped on some
nuts
no don't applaud for that one can a crap
with it what's the difference this time
we we went back to polyester okay look
guys guys come on I've given you three
chances don't you don't you guys want to
make it in the music business
Conan we've already made it we're at the
top of the music business okay what are
you talking about nobody respects you
guys everyone respects us check out the
ad for our new tribute album man for
years the slip nuts have been musical
Mavericks influencing a whole generation
of artists and now those artists are
paying them back with tribute on nuts a
tribute to the slip nuts featuring Steve
Winwood
[Music]
Patti Smith
[Music]
oh that's old play with doughnuts
looking down past episode nuts a
spanish-language version from most Lobos
we're slip and John Mayer
around it slipping on yeah we'll just
slip nice we're sipping on nuts yeah
keep that down and slip down some nuts
tribute on nuts available now for just
four easy payments of $63.99 buy it
today all proceeds go directly into the
slip nuts for food shelter and alimony
[Applause]
you really all respect it take it away
fellas we need money no if ands or buts
again I slipped on some nuts
[Applause]